Немає сумніву в тому, що
Кремль руками Лукашенка, при допомозі,
таки поборе опозицію.
Але  це вже не перемога Лукашенка,
це  буде перемога Кремля.
Наскільки Україна готова протидіяти імовірним загрозам?
На території Білорусі є три російські військові бази.
майже 15 тисяч прекрасно підготовлених
представників Збройних сил РФ.
…проведення місцевих виборів в Донбасі?
Дурниця повна, тому що
вибори провести там неможливо.
треба припиняти навіть розмови про реінтеграцію…
Пане Безсмертний, десять років тому Ви були послом України в Білорусі.
У політичній площині Білорусь практично не зазнала жодних змін за цей час.
А от що, на Вашу думку, змінилося у свідомості білорусів,
що спонукало так багато людей спочатку підтримати на виборах
Світлану Тихановську, а потім і вийти на вулиці?
В боротьбі за білоруську Білорусь бере участь третє покоління.
Особливість цього покоління
в тому, що воно позбавлене
радянських ментальностей
і радянських "моральностей",
воно абсолютно вільно  від комуністичних і посткомуністичних переконань.
А Лукашенко не врахував одну річ.
Він тіснув на суспільство, тиснув на громадян,
але закрити суспільство, як це було в радянські часи
"залізним парканом", він не міг і не зміг.
Тому люди тягнуться до людяності.
Фраза про те, що "Тихановська -випадкова людина",- повна дурниця!
Чому? Тому що білорус  в кінці кінців хоче жити, як людина.
Йому вже набрид цей диктатор,
який "з Божої ласки благословляв добро" і хоче бути паханом!
У Світлани Тихановської є політичне майбутнє?
Не тільки в неї.  Насправді в цього покоління
білорусів велика перспектива.
Вони не усвідомлюють того, наскільки вони зараз високо стрибнули.
Для мене очевидно, що  вони вже перемогли.
Мова йде тільки про те, як формально Тихановська
і теперішнє покоління білоруських політиків
отримає ці механізми влади.
Поки що це період протистояння.
Це такий пат.
Він  може протягнутися до 70 днів.
В протистоянні є запас міцності, нервів.
Київ тримався 71 день,
Одеса трималися 71 день,
Помаранчева революція  71 день,
Революція Гідності в протистоянні режиму 71 день,
Паризька комуна  71 день.
Це запас насправді психологічної стійкості в період протистояння,
коли нерви не дозволяють не зайти за " червоні прапорці".
Після цього наступає розв’язка.
І ця розв’язка або
цивілізовано пройде до цього часу,
або наступить розв’язка  трагічним способом після цього часу.
Мирні протести тривають, але Олександр Лукашенко,
як бачимо, не готовий мирно віддати владу.
Ваш прогноз, чи вдасться білоруському народові
добитися призначення нових президентських виборів?
Переконаний в тому, що вибори будуть і президентські і парламентські.
Я не сумніваюся в тому, що демократична Білорусь переможе.
Проблема тільки в тому, яку  позицію в цьому займе зараз Кремль.
І от тут для урівноваження  ситуації
важливий баланс між позицією Європи і світу, і Кремля.
Ось, що важливо.
Якщо, умовно кажучи, Європа і світ забезпечить рівність балансу,
то білоруський народ диктатора свого погонить.
Якщо це не вдасться забезпечити,
немає сумніву в тому , що Кремль руками Лукашенка,
при допомозі, таки поборе опозицію.
Але  це вже не перемога Лукашенка, це  буде перемога Кремля.
Чи погоджуєтеся Ви  з тим, що будь-який кандидат на посаду президента Білорусі,
якщо будуть призначені нові вибори, так чи інакше обере проросійський вектор?
Я би пропонував зараз судити про це не з Києва, не з Берліна, а з Мінська.
Той, хто там знаходиться, той розуміє, що країна на п’ять шостих
знаходиться сьогодні в системі координат РФ.
Вона не вміє , поки що не знає і
не може бути за межами цього механізму.
Як він довго затягнеться,  життя покаже.
Очевидно, що обравши проєвропейській шлях,
Білорусь, рано чи пізно зайде в піке з  Кремлем так,
як зайшла Україна, але то буде потім.
Є версія, що Лукашенку доведеться сісти на літак та залишити країну,
як колись зробив експрезидент України Віктор Янукович.
Це ймовірно?
Це один з варіантів. Він прекрасно усвідомлює,
що все те, що відбудувалося в дні протесту вже - це матеріал  для Гааги.
Такі злочини не підпадають під помилування чи термін давності.
А це означає, що в нього  шансів залишатися в Білорусі немає.
Яка країна може його прийняти?
На сьогоднішній день це таких країн вже дві
де навіть є для нього резиденції для нього. Це Росія і Китай.
Ще минулого року Ви заявили, що Україна має розуміти
що окрім небезпеки зі сходу,
є ще певні загрози з півночі.
Як Ви оцінюєте ситуацію нині?
Один з можливих мирних варіантів розвитку подій в Білорусі,
це коли в момент загострення
буде формалізована агресія РФ
і буде запущено процес аншлюсу.
Для цього всі правові підстави і фактичні.
Білоруський диктатор, тобто президент,
формально, згідно з Конституцією, має право
укладати зовнішньо-політичні угоди  і їх ратифікувати.
Тому, якщо ситуація  загостриться і дійде до крайності в протистоянні,
я не виключаю, що Кремль зайде формально на територію Білорусі.
Він фактично зараз там присутній.
До речі, це те що мене вражає і дивує. Всі сором’язливо замовчують
участь спецназу РФ зараз в протидії  протестуючим,
участь кадрових військ і РФ в республіці Білорусь в протидії протестуючим,
хоча  всі знають, що на території Білорусі є три російські військові бази.
Не дві, а три.  Три з минулої осені
Загальна кількість військових сягає майже 15 тисяч
прекрасно  підготовлених представників Збройних сил РФ.
Тому, це треба розуміти.
Президент Білорусі привів у готовність армію.
Як Ви думаєте, наскільки Україна готова
протидіяти імовірним загрозам?
Це тактичний крок був для того, щоб звільнити бази і казарми
в Вітебській , Гомельській і Могильовській  областях, вивести війська на захід,
а їхні місця зайняли російські війська.
Російські війська увійшли без маркування, без пізнавальних знаків.
Це найслабше місце в  безпеці і обороні України,
тому що всі 1000 км кордону
фактично фортифікаційними спорудами не забезпечені,
бойовими одинцями не забезпечені.
Більше того з 12 -ти переходів лише три врегульовані і  облаштовані.
Решта - це більше лісові дороги.
Більше того після навчань "Захід 2017" на території Білорусі,
цій зоні залишилося дуже багато бронетехніки.
Я сподіваюся, що найближчим часом і верховний головнокомандувач,
і Генштаб приймуть рішення, які забезпечать
оборону держави на випадок прямої агресії.
Протестувальники в Мінську просили міжнародну спільноту
не визнавати перемогу Лукашенка.
Чому українські дипломати відреагували не одразу?
Перші два тижня це було млява абсолютно реакція.
Від України чекали дуже активних дій,
тому що всі чудово розуміли в світі, в Європі особливо,
що Україна розуміє генеалогію цих процесів.
Але, очевидно, що політичне керівництво України ув’язло
в домовленостях і договорняках, я буду використовувати саме це слово, з Москвою,
тому воно було на початку паралізоване.
Потім під тиском суспільства почали  проговорювати певні фрагменти.
І вже треба сказати, що останні заяви
Зеленського про необхідність перевиборів,
правда без оцінки того, що відбувається,
свідчить про те, що ми прокинулися.
Але з точки зору моєї, це  запізніла оцінка,
яка ще більше дистанціонує Україну від європейської спільноти.
І ще більше дистанціонує Україну від системи оборони НАТО.
Як Ви думаєте, наскільки може бути заморожена робота Мінської контактної групи
враховуючи ситуацію в Білорусі?
З березня місяця фактично контактна група працює в онлайн-режимі
можна сказати, що вона тільки називається,  як "мінська".
На моє переконання, пандемія не залишає шансів нам працювати в іншій формі.
На моє переконання, пандемія не залишає шансів сьогодні
нам працювати в іншій формі.
Форма онлайн-режиму буде зберігатися.
Але "Мінськ ", як платформа, за нинішніх умов,
очевидно, що не може використовуватися  з технологічних причин.
Ви доволі часто і різко критикували останні
домовленості в Мінську щодо "режиму тиші".
Мовляв, Київ фактично проявив слабкість,
а президент Зеленський нібито жадає аплодисментів від Кремля
більше, ніж від свого народу.
Наразі, за словами президента України, вже місяць ніхто не стріляє
убік українських військових.
Чи не змінили Ви змінили свої попередні оцінки?
То неправда, що  ніхто не стріляв.
Чого немає…. Немає діяльності снайперів
і немає диверсійно-розвідувальних груп.
Але постріли лунають кожного дня, це перше..
Друге - зверніть увагу це чи не єдиний випадок,
коли "режим тиші " був ініційований Росією, а не Україною.
Тут є проста відповідь. Кремль прекрасно розумів перспективи ситуації в Білорусі.
Кремль  вже не справляється.
Лівія, Сирія, Україна, Білорусь.
Тому їм потрібна була передишка.
Вони отримали цю передишку через абсолютну нерозторопність
і нерозуміння політичної ситуації українським керівництвом,
яке  нинішню ситуацію  може в усіх складових використати
для того, щоб здобути перемогу і в "Мінську", і на фронті, і в "Норманді".
Як Ви думаєте, навіщо президент Зеленський вирішив ввести в контактну групу
по Донбасу експрезидента Кравчука і експрем’єра Фокіна?
Перше: з українського боку в нинішній ситуації не можна бути без статусних фігур.
І це добре, що і  президент,  і його оточення це розуміють.
Погано, що вони не розуміють, що "мінський процес "  і "новоогарьовський " процес -
як кажуть в Одесі,  це дві різні речі.
Хоча для Кремля це приємна річ,  тому що є можливість
згадати бажання про відновлення СРСР і очевидно, що Кремль
в позиції і пана Кравчука, і пан Фокіна буде апелювати до цього  процесу.
Але вернутися в той процес неможливо, а це означає, що
скоріш за все, "Мінському процесу " приготовлена участь
непродуктивної безрезультатної балаканини.
Як Ви ставитесь до звернення першого президента України Кравчука до Верховної Ради
з приводу проведення місцевих виборів в Донбасі?
Дурниця повна, тому що вибори провести там неможливо.
Більше того, саме рішення є неконституційне, а  люди,  які спробують його реалізувати,
підпадуть під кримінальну відповідальність.
Питання це неодноразово розглядалося в "Мінському процесі".
Можу вам сказати: якщо, умовно кажучи, рішення про вибори прийнято,
то технологічно, якщо Україна буде контролювати як держава ту сторону,
це можливо зробити технологічно не менше, ніж через півтора-два роки.
А політично це не менше 5.
Чи хотіли би Ви знову брати участь у перемовинах Мінської контактної групи? На яких умовах?
На жаль, я не бачу можливості використати свої підходи з нинішньою командою,
яка працює там, особливо з командою, яка сидить на Банковій, в цьому процесі.
Я сьогодні вже усвідомлюю, виходячи з аргументації  і фактів, що треба
припиняти навіть розмови про реінтеграцію, треба приймати державну програму
про відселення лояльних до України людей з Криму і Донбасу
і застосовувати концепцію співіснування. Росія настільки напакостила за цей час,
що треба буде час, щоб лікувати це. Сьогодні  Україна не в силі опанувати ці території.
Які висновки українська влада має зробити з подій, які відбуваються в Білорусі?
Лише один нюанс, на який треба звернути увагу.
Скільки вовка не годуй, він все рівно залишається вовком.
Я маю на увазі стосунки з РФ.
По мірі того, як Лукашенко буде не потрібний Кремлю, вони з ним розпрощаються.
Це привіт нинішньому політичному керівництву, яке повинно чітко розуміти:
доки існує Україна як незалежна держава, доки існує Росія як незалежна держава,
Росія і Кремль буде все робити, щоб знищити Україну як незалежну державу.
Їм вдалося розправитися з Білоруссю як із незалежною державою,
і вони мріють, окупувавши Білорусь, знищити незалежність балтійських держав і України.
Тому не випадково легендами навчань "Захід" були удар на Південь та на Сувальський коридор,
Тому оце речі, які необхідно пам’ятати.
Як Україна може допомогти  Білорусі?
По-перше, ініціювати розгляд ситуації зараз в Білорусі в Раді безпеки ООН,
на різних рівнях ОБСЄ. Україна вже зіткнулася  за останні 20 років
із усіма цими проблемами і знає дорогу до тих, хто робить це.
Ще одна  річ дуже важлива: санкційний вплив України не менший,
ніж будь-якої держави світу  на Білорусь. І тут рішення українського уряду є суперважливі.
І наступна річ.
Україні треба прогнозувати  декілька можливих сценаріїв розвитку події в Білорусі.
Якщо Литва і Польща заявляє, що готова прийняти біженців, Україна мовчить.
Більше того, Україна не міняє навіть режим…
Україна ж приймає?
…не міняє режиму митного контролю з Білоруссю, що абсолютно неправильно.
Так, по факту Україна робить ці кроки. Тільки завдяки тому, що певні посадові особи
йдуть на компроміс з законом.  Я м’яко зараз кажу…
Яких наслідків слід очікувати Україні?
Очевидно, ці наслідки будуть… загальмовані процеси євроінтеграції,
загальмування процесу співпраці з країнами НАТО, з блоком НАТО.
Очевидно це перетворить Україну в самотнього борця проти російської агресії,
що є дуже небезпечним в нинішній ситуації. Перемога демократичної  Білорусі відкриває
шанс, навпаки, на об’єднання центральноєвропейських держав
у протидії російський агресії. Це і безпека Європи, це  і власна безпека.
Президент Зеленський оголосив 30-й рік Незалежності роком закінчення війни в Донбасі.
Чи є підстави так вважати?
Зрозуміло, що  кожному з нас хотілося би, щоб ця війна припинилася.
Але якщо ви подивитеся окремі складові: інформаційна, економічна, енергетична,
пряма експансія, пряма агресія ведеться не тільки в Україні.
Президенту Путіну не дають спокою лаври Грозного, Сталіна тощо.
Він живе з ідеєю  відродження імперії, тому Росія буде домагатися формування імперії
і знищення тих держав, які вискочили силоміць із імперії.
Насправді світ зараз стоїть перед колосальною загрозою.
Або вгамує ці імперські пристрасті, або стане  перед вибором спочатку континентальної,
а потім глобальної війни. Для мене це очевидно. І тут треба вибирати:
або об’єднувати зусилля і допомагати білорусам, продовжувати рятувати Україну,
або стати жертвою цього процесу.
Дуже дякую.